prove them wrong prove you wrong do them
one prove people wrong
hello believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet so to help you
on your journey today we're gonna learn
how to prove people wrong and as always
if you hear something that really
resonates with you please leave it down
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired and
if you're leaving a comment within the
first few hours of this video going live
you have a chance to win one of two
daily prizes that we have good luck did
you ever have let's call it a normal job
Connor a nine-to-five yeah because the
oldest thing is the games were trade
straight away I was no different
soon as I finished skill I was always
getting pestered what are you doing with
your life you known this day on that and
they didn't know what it was they didn't
know MMA wasn't known I didn't know it
could make a career ever as far as they
were concerned me mind I'm talking about
as far as they were concerned I've just
get into a cage of fighting some other
guy they didn't know nothing about it
no one did really but I knew and I mean
I knew or there and then I got end up
getting a trade just to keep them quiet
Azusa had a lot a lot of fights with me
dialogue like a trade did you get I end
up getting a trade as a plumber and
literally opened the back eyes and I
whereupon we cloak the week-long
mountain and fleeing like that but say
it was one of the biggest sites in
Europe kill Tiernan was right at that
ski in place huge and now it's just
abandoned now it's just deserted so used
to go up there six o'clock five-spoke
trotting Amano's on that m50 I just had
to walk to the end for about half an
hour from your hell was way for some
memory card I didn't even know he drove
on the m4 and I had to flag him down
nightmare you have two hours down on the
m-52 hours by usually 14-hour days and I
was there I was the first year so I was
the I had to go and do everything like
to go to the shop I'd to go and get this
and get that so I always had trouble
down I was like this isn't for me this
is not for me how long did you last I
lasted 18 18
one stealing well it was tough you know
I just wasn't wasn't alive for me and
I'm and then and then John said because
I was training with Jonna as well at the
time and then John got on Twitter says
there I have a show I'm on the show
would like to fight honey and then that
was he I just packed it in didn't show
up weed I used to come in and punch the
head on me and like try and drag me out
Beth and I just wouldn't go and I mean
had Oprah off for a good few years when
I'm all verbal and and that was there I
just packed it in quit and then focused
on training and that's I knew I knew I
knew what was gonna happen I knew I was
gonna get here they didn't there's a lot
of stressful years you know a lot of
tough times and but I proved them wrong
I proved myself right don't ever let
somebody tell you you can't do something
[Music]
not even me
all right
you got a dream
you got to protect it
people can't do something themselves
they want to tell you you can do it
[Music]
you want something go get it period
you're not against bullying I'm not I
mean I'm not against like bullying
because I feel like the world is bullies
like there's so many people who are
gonna tell you that what you're right
your idea is stupid or like you don't
belong here or you don't deserve certain
things and wouldn't it be a better maybe
a better place if people didn't do that
but you're saying you you're not against
ACCA's it's unrealistic to being ASA I'm
saying like we probably wouldn't have
Kanye West Bill Gates or anyone without
someone being like you're not worth it
like we wouldn't have them and like we
wouldn't have people who were like no
this is worth it because if everybody if
everybody's ideas was worth it and if
they felt that way everybody felt like
that idea we just have it be just like
nothing everything would be the same you
need somebody to keep being like I would
know I'm right you need a Joan of Arc
who's like no I'm right I'm right I'm
right I'm right even if it's crazy even
if it's great but like then eventually
people like me they're not are you that
way
I mean yeah I like to believe that I
mean people don't seem like such a
little modest guy and when you're on the
show I'm a salty dude though are you oh
yeah I remember everybody who system
like I mean like I got beefs with people
like I remember stuff
I remember totally and I'm like most of
the things I do is just like no I'm
right I mean I believe in myself your
vengeful not vengeful I'm salty I'm like
the difference the difference would be
like vengeful is like I'm gonna come and
destroy you I think like it's like I'm
gonna win I'm gonna take your taking
your number down and I'm coming for you
no man for you I'm salty what you mean I
think salty is a different thing because
I'm like I'm just gonna prove you wrong
I'd much rather you sit there and be
like huh I was wrong because then I
think that's that's growing like there's
lots of times where I've done stuff in
me like I was wrong about that and I
didn't even know and then it makes you
like look at things differently um
experiences in your life like I I want
to make people think like you were wrong
ignore people telling you your idea is
bad they may be right but the only way
to know is to actually build it out
and I think the thing that works about
Silicon Valley it's different than
Mexico City or almost anywhere else in
the world is the default response if
someone says hey I'm gonna start a
startup here's my idea the default
response is to be excited and think like
oh why might that work and in most of
the rest of the world the default
response when you tell someone your idea
is to say oh that's not going to work
and this is really toxic for startups
because you have to believe in yourself
and and the good idea is because they
sound like bad ideas are so fragile and
so killable that you have to be really
careful to insulate yourself against
this one I found some place in my
country and a later once at the
telephone I then asked to whom am i
speaking
she said you're speaking to me I said
well lady I know I'm speaking to you but
what's your name she said who are you to
ask for my name what's your name I say
one lady as soon as you tell the order
I'll tell you mine but as we argued as
to who should tell his or her name she
became very close and she said you seem
to be a backward person have you passed
out my trick
now my trick in our country is a
university and reexamination and I said
that well lady among the very careful
because if the qualification to speak to
you is the possession of a metric
certificate
I might work hard and pass my MA trick
and be in the same class as you are that
was treason she said you will never be
in my class and paint the telephone how
I wish she was here today
she would now discover that I have
achieved more I'll pass my my trick and
and you know when they say oh I would
like you to to do this for me or and I
produce a lot of first-time filmmakers
but I don't produce all the first-time
filmmakers that approach me and I say
look if I say no and you give up I'm
sorry to tell you but it's the wrong job
for you
because you live with rejection for
decades sometimes as a director and you
end up making the movie you want to make
so if I say no that doesn't mean I'm
right or I'm wrong you just say him I'll
show him later you know I'm gonna make
it and that fat bastard is gonna have to
say I was so wrong and hit himself in
the head because he didn't do it
and I think that that's the thing to do
is like show us
don't tell us you know do the things and
if you do them wrong but you do em in
your own terms that's how I define
success failing in your own terms do you
think that people underestimate you
underestimate your how much you work on
this stuff underestimate your
intelligence and and my question is is
that something you push back on or
something you leverage definitely
something that doesn't bother me
um when someone underestimates me I love
to get to know them and have them have
one conversation with me to just
understand that it's I mean I think the
easiest question to ask is what does she
do what is your talent you know and I
jerking lee said actually to my husband
the other day I said you know what how
my next dancer should be like
sarcastically how lucky am i if I don't
sing and I don't dance but I'm still
doing what I'm doing how easy is my job
I don't have to do any of that I don't
have to be on stage like you working you
know so hard but we're still driving the
same car we're still living the same
vibe you know
lucky me you know if it was that easy
but you know I think it's just like the
easiest thing to ask for anyone to
really assume that it's not a full-time
job to have to sit and create things and
come up with every single blog post and
I do you know three a day and having to
you know working on apps if it's to me
it would be the same thing as people
saying like anything blogging like what
do you do you're sitting at home and
your apartment and you're just on the
computer like that do you think people
do say everything work doesn't say that
you know and I respect it so much you
know and they say that you know about
the modeling world well they just sit
there looking pretty it is a full-time
job for you know models like you know my
sister even you know Kendall it's I I
don't mind getting underestimated but I
feel I feel for people that I understand
how it could bother them if they were
put in the same situation even filming a
reality show it's a full-time job I mean
I think that I know you know reality
shows don't get the respect that I
believe they deserve and that's why I
love being on one for so long and I will
you know always fight to you know be on
as long as possible because I love to
show and prove but my personality is
just if you underestimate me I would
love to have a conversation with you I
would love to I just like to prove
people wrong but I was done on the pasta
one night into the sink and all of a
sudden Ramone Simone walks in and he
says you know Barbara we have something
serious to discuss I'm gonna marry a
secretary like Tina
she went from Tina the wonderful
secretary I won't even put a label on
her
I just couldn't believe my ears or my
eyes like what how's that possible
he said take meat I'm moving out I took
about a minute granted a toothbrush and
walked out the door moved in with my
girlfriend Cathy who was living on East
79th Street in the studio and she let me
stay there till I got my feet back home
to me I should say for the first time my
life I don't know what hit me I guess
that hit me but I can't believe I
managed it so bad I felt like I was in
nobody I went from a somebody with a
successful business for nobody because I
was turned out for a younger woman
Tina was five years younger than me I
had to admit she was prettier she had
real blonde hair I was already
highlighting I hated her that she was
calm and pretty I hated her
but I went to work every day I wanted a
fire Tina but Ray reminded me he was a
controlling partner I couldn't do that
Tina moved into my desk in Ray's office
where I used to sit and I set out with
the salespeople and every day I went in
smiling like a puppet but in my heart I
was running around a broken heart and
loss of confidence I just thought to
myself my god I was nothing before ray
found he picked me out found me he was
my mentor he gave me confidence he gave
me the money to start the business
everything good that had changed my life
all led to one place which was her lungs
alone and I thought he's right I'll
never succeed with that but I can't even
remember what clicked in my head
maybe desperation but one day I just
decided I'm not gonna do this anymore
and I walked in and I said to Ramone
Simone you know what I'm ending this
business and here's how we're gonna do
it we're gonna chop up the 14 sales
people like a football draw you could
pick the first person I'll pick the
second we'll do it fair if you want to
move out you can move out if you want me
to move out no problem you want to keep
the phone in with no problem or I'll get
a new phone number whatever you go first
he picked Norman Hirsch our star sales
person I picked Estrella capital I'm not
so star sales person but I had a plan
for her and we went right down the line
and I would say within maybe six minutes
we ended a partnership boom like that we
had $37,000 in cash he wrote me a check
for half the $37,000 and as luck would
have it it was a real estate recession
we're just about to dive into and why
was it great because commercial space
wasn't leasing well he was on the eighth
floor where my old office was I rented
the identical space on the 11th floor
above him there's a little ego in there
and I'm sorry to say
was I and by the Monday this was on a
Thursday by Monday I move my salespeople
incus and those times you could rent
black desk rent phones by you were in
operation and my seven salespeople moved
in and that was the birth of the
corporate group right before I left
Ramon Simone's office that day or I
should say raving Tina's office that day
and by the way you know what his real
name was wasn't even where most of all I
fired from his mother Vicky his real
name was Ray Simon and he wasn't from
the best country like he always told me
he was from 145th Street Marlon go
figure already well anyway so right
before I left the office that's when ray
gave me the gift of a lifetime when he
said to leave me those words that
reflected in my head for the rest of my
life it still gets me going you'll never
succeed without me I'm telling you I
don't believe in negative motivation
what positive person like my mother but
he really knew my number if he had said
I know you're gonna be amazing I'm sure
I would have stayed in business and the
tough times but it was that scolding
tattoo in my heart you'll never succeed
without me that every time I was near
death growing my business through the
ups and downs of the real estate
recession me overextended being over
leveraged only money
blah blah blah that same phrase got me
going again
he gave me an insurance policy for
successfully insulting me thank God he
did I have thanked him a million times
what happened were moms alone you
married Tina they have three kids
together
they are so much more happily married
than myself and my husband Bill they
were meant to be together
they were in Destin okay but still thank
God he gave me that insult to assure my
success for the rest of my life do not
listen to the naysayers if you are going
to have a breakthrough you've got to be
able to silence the negative voices
that's the next step and that's the next
secret many of us have too many people
speaking into our ears I just call these
people abortionists so you've got to be
careful your dreams your vision your
desires especially those that have been
god-given I want you to pursue them I
want you to believe that all things are
possible it is possible for you to go
back to school it is possible for you to
heal your relationship it is possible
for you to go at like a loan it is
possible seems to be that manages well
the countries come and they are quickly
addicted to the place yeah have you
spoke to anybody on our behalf they told
me is so hard so tough and all the
people say PAP is not going to adapt in
that code in that way so that's why I'm
here to try to to do it so the people
have some of them confident it's going
well but some of them are we in Germany
as well the people say the way you play
is not be possible here in in the
Premier League so and I said myself why
not why we don't travel there to try it
and that's why so it's a big challenge
not just for me but I am I was in in my
team was able to involve the players and
it's going to happen here as well when
that's happened everything will be easy
thank you guys so much for watching and
I hope you enjoyed the video I'd love to
know what did you think what was a
single biggest takeaway that you took
from this video that you're going to
apply to your life or to your business
somehow leave it down in the comments
below if you're within the first couple
hours of this video going live you have
a chance to win one of two daily prizes
as well I also want to give a quick
shout out to Eduardo Eduardo thank you
so much you're picking up a copy of my
book your one word and taking that
picture and posting it to Facebook I
really appreciate the support man
I hope you enjoyed the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love I'll see you soon
[Music]